Hallöchen ihr Lieben und willkommen zum ersten Video meiner diesjährigen Ramadan-Reihe!
Wie ihr vermutlich in den letzten Jahren schon mitbekommen habt, ist immer das erste Video meiner Ramadan-Reihe
ein "Quatsch Video". Also kein Quatsch in dem Sinne sondern ein Laber Video!
Da reden wir einfach so ein bisschen über den Ramadan, wollen aber nicht so tief in die Materie
sondern es soll auch darum gehen: Was erwartet euch auf meinem Kanal in den nächsten 4 Wochen?
Denn der Ramadan ist ein Fastenmonat, in dem Muslime 29 oder 30 Tage lang fasten.
Es ist natürlich so, dass meine Community - die Kikimunity wie ich sie immer nenne - nicht nur aus Muslimen besteht,
sondern aus ganz vielen verschiedenen Religionen oder auch Nicht-Religionen
und da sind natürlich alle willkommen und ich denke von Rezepten profitiert einfach je-der!
Aber natürlich isst und trinkt man 30 Tage lang nichts tagsüber
und erst wenn die Sonne untergeht darf man sein Fasten brechen.
Und da möchte ich einfach ein bisschen Inspiration geben und euch durch den Monat begleiten.
Und allem voran eine Info: Ihr hab's in den letzen Wochen mitbekommen - mein Kochbuch ist endlich da!
Ihr konntet es zwar schon vorbestellen; jetzt habt ihr aber die Möglichkeit, es auch noch zu eurer Bestellung im Shop hinzuzufügen
da jetzt die Vorbestellungen rausgehen und auch das Kochbuch an sich halt wirklich da ist.
Ihr werdet aber auch noch ein gesondertes Video von mir zum Kochbuch bekommen
und ich finde das ist der perfekte Begleiter zum Ramadan aber auch für das ganze restliche Jahr
mit süßen und herzhaften Rezepten.
Das hier sind übrigens unsere palästinensischen Datteln
und in dem Video heute zeige ich euch auch so ein bisschen: Was gibt's Neues im Kikis Kitchen Shop?
denn nicht jeder folgt uns auf Instagram.
Und was ganz besonders ist und Gott sei Dank konnten wir das noch einrichten:
pünktlich zum Ramadan gibt's die palästinensischen Medjool Datteln.
Die sind extra dick, extra groß und haben sehr viel Fruchtfleisch
und - jetzt lobe ich dich mal so richtig! -
Die Grafik kommt von Hamza, guckt euch das mal an.
Er meinte weil seine Mama - also meine Schwiegermama - immer palästinensische Kleider trägt,
die haben immer dieses typische Muster, hat er sich für diese Grafik entschieden.
Ich find das so süß. Du bist toll Schatz!
[Hamza] Dankeschön!
Und auf der Rückseite steht noch ein  Reim. Also ist das ein Rap-Reim oder ist das ein Gedicht?
[Hamza] Ja, ich hab bisschen gerappt!
[Kiki] Okay.
Ich glaub ich verrat's noch nicht in dem Video.
Ihr könnt's euch ja dann mal angucken, ich werd' euch den Link hier unten in die Infobox setzen.
Wir machen heute - also wir quatschen nicht nur, wir machen heute auch noch ein leckeres Rezept.
Nämlich habe ich mir gedacht wir machen Dattelpudding
und das ist so eine Art Schichtdessert und das könnt ihr einfach auch als kleines Dessert anbieten.
Und da fange ich jetzt direkt mal an, die Datteln einzuweichen.
Das könnt ihr entweder in normalem lauwarmem Wasser über Nacht
oder halt jetzt mit kochendem heißem Wasser für nur 10min damit sie schön weich werden.
Das Gute ist, dass ihr die Verpackung wiederverschließen könnt
und kleiner Hinweis: dadurch, dass die Datteln besonders viel Fruchtfleisch enthalten,
es gibt ganz viele verschiedene Dattelsorten aber die hier solltet ihr im Kühlschrank lagern
damit sie möglichst lange frisch bleiben.
Ho-ho-ho!
Das sind richtige Oschis! Die sind so lecker.
Datteln sind übrigens super gesund!
Reich an Kalium, Magnesium, B-Vitaminen..
Also super, super gesunder Snack.
Aber wir verarbeiten's jetzt zu einem Dattelpudding!
Nachdem ihr die Datteln nur 5-10min lang eingeweicht habt,
einfach abgießen und pürieren.
Ihr dürft auch gern von dem Dattelwasser ein bisschen was dazugeben
und das Püree sieht dann so aus.
Und ihr müsst euch vorstellen: Datteln sind ja von Natur aus sehr süß,
daher würde ich hier fast sagen ihr braucht gar keinen zusätzlichen Zucker für das Rezept.
Ich habe hier ein bisschen Rohrzucker,
da könnte man vielleicht selber persönlich nochmal abschmecken aber es ist wirklich Geschmackssache.
Okay, Abschmecken ist so eine Sache - wo wir grad beim Stichwort sind!
Man isst und trinkt ja den ganzen Tag über nichts. Nein, nicht mal Wasser!
Und das ist das, wo sich immer viele wundern.
[Hamza] Auch nicht rauchen!
[Kiki] Nicht rauchen!
Also an alle Raucher, die müssen sich dann auch gedulden
wobei Rauchen ja eh so 'ne Geschichte ist.
[Hamza] Ist die beste Phase, aufzuhören!
[Kiki] Ist die beste Phase, damit aufzuhören!
Ich werde hier parallel schon mal alle Zutaten in meine Schüssel geben.
Und viele wundern sich: "Hä, ist das nicht voll ungesund? Ihr trinkt nicht mal 'nen Schluck Wasser, gerade wenn's so warm ist!"
In den letzten Jahren war's auch immer richtig heiß an Ramadan.
Ich muss sagen es ist 'ne Gewohnheitssache, oder Hamza?
Wie kommst du denn damit klar? Erzähl mal!
[Hamza] Also ich komme damit schon lange zurecht.
[Kiki] Hamza fastet ja auch schon ziemlich lange.
[Hamza] Als Kind habe ich auch gefastet.
[Hamza] Aber jetzt kommt ja der Clou: Warum habe ich als Kind oder als 10-jähriger gefastet?
[Hamza] Es war so, dass die Sonne bereits um 16-17h untergegangen ist, das war gar kein Problem!
[Kiki] Du kamst von der Schule..
[Hamza] Von der Schule direkt gegessen!
Okay, das heißt du hast dich als Kind schon mal ganz gut daran gewöhnt.
Ich muss sagen es ist wirklich eine Gewöhnungssache aber es ist nicht ungesund
denn der Mensch kann tatsächlich ganz lange ohne Wasser zu trinken aushalten.
Das ist so ein bisschen auch eine Ausreinigung des Körpers
aber es ist ja nicht nur das, sondern eigentlich vielmehr was Spirituelles.
Weil im Prinzip weiß niemand außer dir und Gott, dass du gerade fastest
weil jeder kann ja sagen "Ja, ich faste" und im Hinterzimmer trinkt man dann Wasser oder isst was.
[Hamza] Eben auf Toilette gehen und dann Wasser trinken!
[Kiki] Eben auf Toilette gehen!
Aber ist halt was mega Spirituelles und so ein bisschen auch Hingabe.
Ich finde auch, dass gerade in diesem Monat man halt auch viel mehr in sich kehren kann.
Falls ihr euch wundert, was ich jetzt hier in der Zwischenzeit gemacht habe:
Ich schreibe euch wie immer alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben in die Videobeschreibung hier unter dem Titel.
Und da habe ich jetzt schon mal Milch, Sahne und ein Ei dazugegeben.
So, ich gebe schon mal die restlichen Zutaten dazu, also Mehl für die Bindung,
ein bisschen Vanilleextrakt wenn ihr mögt, ich find's sehr lecker in Pudding
und natürlich unsere gerade vorgefertigte Dattelpaste.
Und dann rühre ich schon mal und schalte dann den Herd ein
und lasse das zu einem Pudding aufkochen.
Und inzwischen ist es nicht mehr so wie vor... wie vielen Jahren?
[Kiki] 10? 15?
[Hamza] 15 Jahren.
..dass das Fastenbrechen um 16:30h war.
Jetzt ist es z.B. am ersten Tag so 20:30h, 20:40h
je nachdem, wo ihr wohnt, wo die Sonne untergeht.
Und warum ist das so, dass man vor 20 Jahren schon um 16h essen konnte
weil da sie Sonne unterging und jetzt so spät?
Das liegt einfach daran, dass der islamische Kalender nicht nach dem Sonnenkalender, sondern nach dem Mondkalender geht.
Und der Ramadan ist einfach der Name des 9. Monats und der wandert immer 10 Tage zurück.
[Hamza] Und für 14 Tage!
Ich hab letztens schon bei Kiki meets Hamza - Das könnt ihr euch mal angucken, ist ein schönes Video geworden! -
Da hab ich ja auch schon mal gesagt: In ein paar Jahren fällt Ramadan und Weihnachten zusammen.
Ich freu mich auf diese Zeit, ich weiß nicht! Ich find's super interessant.
Also bei uns in der Ramadan Reihe ist es so -
Wir sind übrigens jetzt im 5. Jahr, also schon fast Jubiläumsjahr!
Da ist es so, dass wir 3x die Woche, also viel, viel öfter als sonst
Rezeptvideos hochladen, hauptsächlich aus dem orientalischen Raum
aber nicht nur türkische und arabische Rezepte
weil wie ihr wisst ist Hamza aus Palästina, viele denken er ist Marokkaner.
Wir machen einfach alles, wonach uns ist und zwar rund um den Globus.
Und ich freue mich drauf, dass ihr wieder mit dabei seid.
Ihr könnt übrigens super gerne die Glocke aktivieren
Weil es ist so, dass wir sonntags safe ein Video hochladen, 100%-ig
aber manchmal denken wir uns: "Ok, laden wir's jetzt Mittwoch und Freitag oder Dienstag und Donnerstag hoch?"
Also aktiviert auf jeden Fall die Glocke weil die Uploadtage sind nicht 100% safe.
[Hamza] Und wir haben noch nicht zu 100% alle Rezepte, ne?
[Hamza] Also es ist so, dass wir noch im Ramadan weiterdrehen.
[Hamza] Das heißt ihr könnt jetzt noch in die Kommentare schreiben, was für Rezepte ihr sehen wollt!
[Kiki] Finde ich richtig cool, finde ich richtig cool!
[Hamza] *lacht*
Nee, weißt du warum ich das so cool finde? Weil meistens ist es ja so:
"YouTube Videos, ach die sind doch vorgedreht!"
Nein, wir sind so eng miteinander verschmolzen, gerade auf Instagram!
Wenn ihr Hamza und mir dort noch nicht folgt, solltet ihr das spätestens jetzt nachholen
damit ihr auch während der ganzen Ramadan Reihe mitbestimmen könnt.
Unter anderem was als nächstes online geht, welches Rezept überhaupt noch kommt..
Aber in dem Zusammenhang muss ich auch sagen: Hamza kann leider nicht in jedem Video den Taste Test machen
weil wir drehen manchmal auch mittags und dann wird's ein bisschen schwierig mit probieren.
[Hamza] Aber wieso? Man darf doch probieren! *lacht*
[Kiki] Neiiin!
Wisst ihr was man aber darf? Wenn ich jetzt z.B. koche, ich koche für meine Familie,
und ich schmecke ab, das darf man sogar während man fastet.
Wenn ich jetzt die Suppe abschmecke ob sie salzig genug ist oder eben nicht - das geht.
[Hamza] Aber Kiki, du bist Profi durch und durch! Du musst doch wissen, wie viel Salz du reintust!
Ja, ich muss sagen mittlerweile muss ich nicht mehr abschmecken
aber gerade am Anfang, wo ich so das Kochen neu gelernt habe, da habe ich auch immer abgeschmeckt.
[Hamza] Also solange man nicht die falsche Absicht hat, ist alles gut.
Genau, es kommt wirklich extrem, extrem oft und eigentlich immer auf die Absicht an.
Hat man die Absicht, überhaupt zu fasten? Ihr könnt jetzt auch nicht sagen:
"Och, heute hab ich jetzt zufällig bis 13h geschlafen, eigentlich könnte das Fasten mir ja mega leicht fallen. Dann faste ich mal heute!"
Das geht natürlich nicht. Man muss sich das wirklich vornehmen und die Absicht fassen.
So, ich hab die Masse jetzt einmal aufkochen lassen, die ist schön dick geworden.
Immer weiterrühren damit sich keine Haut bildet, wir werden sie jetzt nämlich noch warm weiterverarbeiten.
Jetzt kommt noch 'ne Neuigkeit, die ihr wahrscheinlich mitbekommen habt wenn ihr uns auf Instagram folgt.
Nachdem wir ja meine Haselnusscreme rausgebracht haben und wir euch so ein bisschen verzaubert haben mit dem Geschmack..
- Ich glaube jeder, der Instagram auch nur geöffnet hat, hat irgendwo in irgendeiner Story die Haselnusscreme gesehen! -
..haben wir jetzt auch die Schokocreme rausgebracht. Ja!
Wir haben die Schokocreme jetzt rausgebracht, die ist seit ein paar Tagen verfügbar.
Ich hatte euch ja erzählt als ich in Ordu war, haben wir quasi schon die Rezeptur für die Schokocreme entwickelt.
Aber wir wollten halt erstmal gucken: Wie kommt die Haselnusscreme an?
Und ja, der ganze Zuspruch spricht für sich.
Und sie ist jetzt da und ich werde jetzt auch meinen Pudding damit verfeinern.
Also gebe ich da jetzt einen großen Esslöffel, vielleicht auch zwei mit rein.
Und dann mache ich daraus ein Schichtdessert.
Wir haben das Ganze gestern abend mal Hamzas Papa probieren lassen, er kannte die Schokocreme nämlich noch nicht
und er ist halt Diabetiker und er mag auch nicht so viel Süßes und er hat probiert und gesagt:
"Was ist das? Das ist einmalig!"
Weil ihr müsst euch vorstellen, dass das 20% weniger Zucker enthält als vergleichbare Produkte.
Es enthält 33% Haselnüsse was an sich schon mal extrem viel ist.
[Hamza] Gerade für eine Schokocreme.
[Kiki] Gerade für eine Schokocreme!
Normalerweise ist der Standard so bei 10-12%, 14 ist sogar schon gut.
[Hamza] Sogar ein bisschen weniger manchmal!
[Kiki] Ja.
Also vergleicht das ruhig mal, schaut euch ruhig mal die Zutaten an
und das Ding ist: es sind halt nicht nur Haselnüsse drin, sondern die erstklassigen.
Ich hab euch ja schon mal erzählt: Haselnüsse werden halt nach Klassen sortiert.
Ich könnte auch viertklassige nehmen, ihr würdet's von außen gar nicht sehen aber man schmeckt das halt.
Und das Allerwichtigste: Es wird doppelt geröstet.
Also nicht nur ein Mal, nein man nehmt die Nüsse und röstet sie noch ein zweites Mal!
Und da kommen einfach so geniale Aromen aus. Einfach unbeschreiblich!
Bitte tut mir einen Gefallen wenn ihr euch die Creme bestellt habt.
Ich habe ja schon gesehen, dass ihr den Shop wieder gestürmt habt.
Bitte schreibt mir euer Feedback hier unten in die Kommentare: Wie hat euch die Creme geschmeckt?
Und vergleicht sie gerne auch mit anderen. Ich bin so überzeugt, ich kann nachts -
Wie ich schon immer so schön sage: Ich kann nachts ruhig schlafen weil ich weiß das ist einfach eine richtig besondere Creme,
die einfach unvergleichbar lecker schmeckt.
[Hamza] Und vor allem auch: Ich muss sagen die meisten denken "Boah, die haben einfach irgendeinen Namen draufgeklatscht".
[Hamza] Wir waren ja so transparent und haben auch die Firmen gezeigt, wo wir sie produzieren lassen.
[Hamza] Aber es ist nochmal was anderes ob man eine eigene Rezeptur hat oder einfach das Rezept von dem Hersteller selber nimmt.
[Hamza] Wir haben unsere eigene Rezeptur, das heißt ihr werdet niemals so eine Creme wie die auf dem Markt bekommen, niemals!
Nein, gibt's nicht. Gibt's einfach nicht!
Und daher bin ich so stolz drauf, dass wir auch dort waren, dass wir uns auf die Reise begeben haben.
Ich kann euch das Video zur Produktion super gerne nochmal in die Videobeschreibung anhängen, schaut's euch gerne an.
Das ist 'ne Creme, die man löffeln kann!
Also bestellt sie euch und nimmt euch 'nen Löffel.
Ihr werdet sehen: Ihr könnt nicht mehr aufhören, ist echt so!
[Hamza] Aber das ist schon krass wieviele Leute das löffeln, ne? Die Leute machen Stories..
[Hamza] Die machen Stories - zieh dir das mal rein - die machen wirklich Stories und die löffeln das.
[Hamza] Und dann haben die halt 3-4 Gläser bestellt und sagen: "Okay, eins ist schon leer!"
Eins ist schon leer weil's wirklich weggelöffelt wurde!
[Kiki] Normalerweise wenn man andere Cremes isst: "Ok süß, nee.."
[Hamza] Zuckerschock!
Zuckerschock.. bei uns gar nicht!
Also ich bin so stolz drauf und ich finde man sollte auch nicht immer so bescheiden sein.
Man kann das ruhig auch mal loben weil ich habe das auch bei mir bemerkt:
Ich bin so schwer darin, mal selbst was zu loben.
Aber was wir auf die Beine gestellt haben - natürlich auch dank euch
weil wenn der Zuspruch nicht kommen würde von euch, dann wäre es gar nicht möglich, noch die Schokocreme auf den Markt zu bringen.
Wartet mal ab, was wir noch vorhaben. An alle Veganer unter euch:
Ihr werdet auch bald davon probieren dürfen, so viel sei verraten.
[Hamza] Zum Sommer hin auf jeden Fall.
[Kiki] Zum Sommer hin schon sogar, genau!
Ich nehme mir jetzt Amarettini und mache sie mit den Händen noch so ein bisschen klein
und dann fange ich einfach an, zu schichten.
Die Datteldesserts habe ich jetzt nochmal mit einfach aufgeschlagener Sahne dekoriert.
Keinen Zucker dazugegeben also wirklich nur aufgeschlagen,
in eine Rosentülle gefüllt und schöne Häubchen aufgespritzt.
Jetzt fehlt mir noch so ein bisschen was Pistazien-mäßiges, ich finde das auch immer so typisch orientalisch.
Was jetzt auch neu ist, sind unsere Pistazien aus Gaziantep.
Ich glaube alle Türken oder auch alle einfach wissen, dass aus Gaziantep die besten Pistazien kommen.
Und ich wollte euch das einfach mal aus der Nähe zeigen.
[Kiki]Schaut euch mal diese Farbe an! Richtig satt-grün mit der lilanen Haut.
[Hamza] Und nicht gefärbt!
Und nicht gefärbt wie Hamza schon sagt weil
tatsächlich ist es so - deswegen merkt Hamza das auch noch extra an -
Es ist wirklich so, dass Pistazien auf dem Markt teilweise auch gefärbt sind. Achtet da immer drauf.
Und da ist wirklich nichts anderes drin als schöne, reife Pistazien aus Gaziantep.
Ich werde jetzt hier nochmal ein bisschen was davon fein hacken
und auf meine Sahnehäubchen geben. Und dann könnt ihr noch Früchte dazugeben
ein Minzblatt, ganz wie ihr mögt.
Das Dessert hält sich dann auch im Kühlschrank 4 Tage lang,
es sei denn ihr habt frische Sahne drauf, dann solltet ihr vielleicht nach dem dritten Tag schon das Ganze verzehren.
[Hamza] Weißt du woran man erkennt, ob die Pistazien gefärbt sind?
[Kiki] Woran denn?
[Hamza] Wenn die glänzen!
[Kiki] Wenn die glänzen. Und wenn die schön matt sind, dann..
[Hamza] Also wenn die glänzen, dann merkt man da ist was gefärbt.
[Hamza] Das sieht man manchmal bei Baklava auch viel.
[Kiki] Ja also einfach mal beim Kauf drauf achten, ob die Pistazien glänzen oder schön matt sind.
[Hamza] Also Leute keine Sorge, unsere Baklava ist nicht so!
Ja, Baklava müsste ich euch jetzt eigentlich auch zeigen. Das ist so ein richtiger Video-Newsletter, ne?
Aber es ist halt echt traurig, dass viele das nicht mitbekommen und dann im Nachhinein sagen:
"Hä, seit wann hast du Baklava?"
[Hamza] Aber Kiki ganz ehrlich, ne? Ohne jetzt einen Vorwurf an dich oder sonst was..
[Hamza] Aber du machst auch nicht viel Werbung!
[Kiki] Das stimmt, das sagen mir auch viele.
[Hamza] Wenn du Werbung machst, dann für deine Produkte. Aber das machst du selten, auch in YouTube Videos machst du das selten.
Ja das stimmt, obwohl wir darauf stolz sein können.
Also die Baklava haben wir zum Opferfest, also zum anderen Bayram rausgebracht letztes Jahr. Die waren ja auch so ruck-zuck weg.
Und das Schöne daran ist: Die sind halt handmade, das ist traditionelle Handarbeit.
Aber ich hab mir eh überlegt:
Ich werde euch ab und zu hier auf YouTube auch so ein paar News geben was es so Neues im Shop gibt
Dann bekommt ihr das auch mal mit.
So, jetzt komme ich auch schon zum Ende dieses Talk Videos.
Ich hoffe, dass euch mein kleines Rezept gefallen hat
und das ihr euch mit mir zusammen und mit Hamza zusammen auf die Ramadan Reihe freut.
Auf jeden Fall wünsche ich euch eine gesegnete Zeit
und vergesst nicht, uns auf Instagram zu folgen damit ihr auch so viel wie möglich mitbestimmen könnt während der Reihe.
Und dann würde ich einfach mal sagen: Bis zum nächsten Video! Tschüss, eure Kiki!